experts in the room yes mr hoffman do
you have a comment we're monitoring the
youtube uh feed and we don't see it yet
so kevin just went okay so i should
repeat everything once we get youtube
spinning probably i think so
all right so so that was good i
i i i
i hate to ruin the surprise for you all
but i'll say something substantially
similar in a few minutes
did you catch
i've been informed that uh youtube is
broadcasting and it's clear that the
microphones are working at least inside
the room so bn212 i will bring us out of
recess on hb1677
the way
we're going to conduct this is that two
days ago
we walked through
a version of
an umberger amendment and we found a
number of places where we thought
alternative language ought to be
considered
we convened a work group the work group
consisted of mr hoffman and mr ripple of
the lba
the attorney general i believe was
directly involved uh represent
general formella
and i believe representative
bob lin
also participated in the work work were
there any other members of the work
group
[Music]
no okay
so um the process i think we can follow
today is to take the
highlighted version of the changes in
the umberger amendment which is
and
mr hoffman will walk us through it he'll
set the stage for
the change that was made and and his his
interpretation of the rationale behind
it and if they're anybody
on the committee that has questions
we'll we'll dive into it at that point
and bring subject matter experts up
and i i would like to encourage um
you know the plaintiff's counsel to be
assertive if uh if you want
to say something i i want you to make
sure you know you have um my permission
to please wave at me and and i want to
have you heard okay
all right so with a stage set uh mr
hoffman would you please uh
lead us off
[Music]
yes thank you
as you recall in the last meeting
the committee took several
straw poll votes on
certain parts of the amendment
and then
agreed that things would be on hold for
the work group to consider
so as kevin put this document together
he's noted that in the margin
so where you see work group removed
that was based on
work of the work group
further down you'll see
language revised by committee
it's just a distinguishing
so mr hoffman um
i should have given you one more um
guideline
uh there are people that need to know
this material because they'll be voting
on it and this for some of them is the
first time they've seen these changes so
so i think we can take our time and and
and and be expansive in the description
of each item if
please sure i just wanted to note the
difference between the the two types of
remarks in in the margin oh okay i
thought you'd already started rolling
and just knocked out two of them already
no not quite that quick okay
so if we look on page one on line
13.
in the earlier versions
a retired judge was listed there as a
possible candidate for administrator the
work group met
and based on the likelihood of a judge
electing to do this
and other complications with the
judicial retirement system
the retired judge was removed from this
section
and if if
to the members of the work group if if
i'm not describing this the way you'd
like to
or reflecting accurately please chime in
and i'll be prone on some of these to
use my judgment of whether or not it's
controversial if i don't think it is i'm
just i won't stop mr hoffman from going
to the next one but if anyone does have
an issue with any of these things again
just get my attention and and we'll make
sure
your care your curiosity is satisfied
at the bottom of the page which is the
next change
the committee had
made this change to the definitions of
physical abuse and sexual abuse
which i believe were
adopting the common law reference and
just uh cleaning up some differences in
the rsa references
um last last two days ago we did not
really
explore
the meaning of single incident and what
that could mean to uh how the guidelines
get developed
and um and we've otherwise have accepted
the plaintiff's language on this
but
i i have concerns that the single
incident may
cause
in this definition i think a single
incident is sufficient to initiate a
claim but what i'm curious about is if
the impact of each incident
being a claim
if or if somebody is abused in the same
way 10 times
is is that 10 individual claims or
would the guidelines incorporate as a
contributing
factor
the fact that there were multiple
incidences and that that would
presumably
change the uh the interpretation of what
part of the range to be on and and we
did not have that conversation but i i'd
like to just make sure we all are in an
agreement and that statute would support
what we're thinking
so um
representative lynn do you have
something to add here
yeah i i i do and i uh in two two
regards one um
as you point out we didn't discuss that
but yesterday in the work group
um
we you know we did sort of focus on this
and
and i think our thinking at the time
yesterday was
that the definite for definitional
purposes it was okay to say a single
incident because as you point out a
single incident should be enough to to
trigger
invoking the process
i
we thought that the way
to to
to make it
the concern we had yesterday was to make
it clear that
whether there was a single incident or
multiple incidents
the cap
applied as a cumulative matter in other
words you well somebody couldn't come in
and say well i was
i was sexually assaulted ten times so
therefore i'm entitled to
you know receive receive the cap for
each one of those so 10 times 1.5
million so we put some language in
roman numeral 5 to cover that
but as you pointed out could you do page
in line sure on on page uh
on page four
line nine lines nine through twelve
we added some language
uh indic you know indicating that the
cap that the cap for both
sexual abuse
and the lower cap for physical abuse
only applies in the aggregate to all
claims
so we
we thought we had covered it but as you
raised as you pointed out to me earlier
before we actually started our meeting
it
arguably it's it
it has not completely covered because
we we did not focus on the situation of
suppose
somebody suppose the guidelines were to
say
you know
some form of physical abuse let's say
uh
would would be worth
let's i'm just making this number up but
let's say they said some form of
physical abuse would be worth ten
thousand dollars
and
then suppose that so it's under well
under the cap but suppose there were ten
incidents of physical abuse of that kind
would that mean that automatically the
number was
ten times you know ten thousand dollars
times ten um i think
um
while the guideline while while the
guidelines may
make factor in the number
of time you know the amount of the abuse
or the number of times it occurs i i
think there was some concern that it
shouldn't just be automatic so you had
suggested i think some language
um that i don't exactly
i don't remember the exact
language that you suggested but i think
it was a good way to handle it
so so my thought on on tweaking the
definition
was so that we don't violate the idea
that a single incident on its own is
sufficient
to to say physical abuse means
a a single incident incident
and then add or multiple incidents
with an s
and so
the my my thought there is that if
a a person is victimized effectively the
same way with a you know a beating
multiple times
it seems to me that we would want to
have one claim filed and not
eight x claims
or whatever the number is so so attorney
general formella we've not talked about
this at all and so
um
what what are your thoughts on how this
term single incident does that really
invite the plaintiffs to file one claim
per
separate incident
thank you mr chair for the question
i don't have a concern about that
reason being that the term claim
is defined as a request for compensation
related to one or more incidents
of sexual abuse and or physical abuse so
i think
the way we've defined the term claim as
one or more incidents
uh would alleviate i think for me at
least the concern that defining physical
abuse as a single incident of conduct or
sexual abuse as a
single incident of conduct it alleviates
the concern that that definition might
lead to the thought that you could
file eight claims for eight incidents i
think
one person
one claimant only gets one claim and
that claim may cover multiple incidents
but the way claim is defined it says one
or more
so
you know i i think that
if you wanted to say means a single
incident or multiple incidents if you
wanted to add or multiple incidents in
physical abuse and sexual abuse i don't
see a concern with that i think it might
be extra bootstrapping but i
i don't believe it's necessary the way i
read the language i i read the intent
and claimants counsel may be able to
speak to this but i read the intent of
adding single incident as just trying to
confirm that
one single incident would be enough to
establish physical abuse or one single
incident would be enough
to establish sexual abuse i think
the cap language that representative lin
mentioned also gets to this concern
because i think that's still
i mean it says 1.5 million dollars for
all claims
so even if someone then tried to submit
multiple claims based on multiple
incidents that each
it's 1.5 million dollars for all claims
so or 100 for all and 150 000 for all
physical abuse only claims
so your position is the definitions fine
as is we don't need to tweak it any
further that would be my position uh i'm
going to ask um the uh mr hayden or or
mr dean dean right
to come up in a moment but
representative weiler do you have a
question
so
i thought we were the physical injuries
to ones that were
dealt with with medical care
and you know we'd likely have somebody
come in and say i was there the guy
named coach woke me up by slapping me in
the face
that's a hundred times i mean we'll have
to hear something like that
representative i think to answer that
question i would say i think the intent
is to address that in the guidelines i
mean i think whether some
whether
something required medical care or not
would be considered as we as we craft
the guidelines
so
so mr
tatum or hate him hate him right not
tatum uh and mr dean um you're you're
welcome to speak you're not obligated to
speak on this
do you care to speak
thank you um
so i yeah i mean i think we agree with
uh representative lin and the attorney
general that no change is needed here
i don't think we ever contemplated that
there would be more than one claim filed
you know i guess i will just state
the caution though that
you know our our clients would
uh
be less inclined to use the process
where there's some kind of devaluing
of subsequent injuries or subsequent
abuses so
you know when we're talking about
somebody that has undergone
you know abuse a dozen times severe
beatings a dozen times
the thought that you know the 12th
beating is worth less than the first
beating would be would be problematic
but
um but yes i mean i think we're in
agreement that each claimant files one
claim
and
while we don't agree with your caps we
we understand that uh
that that's where this subcommittee is
so
mr hayden do you agree yeah okay he's
nods his head yes is there any comment
from
committee members
so so i think we can move on i'm sorry
uh representative mooney thank you mr
chairman uh just to point your attention
to page 3
line 25
the frequency and duration of those acts
is very clearly stated as part of the
formula for valuing claims
so i just wouldn't want that to
be in contradiction with the word single
in on page one
me
i don't know since representative lynn
do you want to respond to representative
mooney since you have a mic in front of
you
no i mean i agree with i agree i think
that that should address the concerns
that uh i mean the point that was raised
uh by by uh council because um
i mean i i think i think this this
statutory scheme will contemplate that
that you know the the frequency of the
of abuse um would be a would be a factor
that would go into valuing
valuing claims and as as it should i
mean i think that that that
seems to me to be you know
something that that that obviously
should be the case and i think we we
captured here
i you know i i think we do understand
that point um that it would be an
aggravating factor
um but it you know it does give more
discretion to the administrator to
to vary and potentially to um
put less value on subsequent harm to
somebody
and that's you know that's just a
concern that we would like to raise
i i think conceivably it could work the
other way too that there'd be an
exponential increase you know for each
one but i i i don't know i'm not the
administrator we'll go with uh
representative rogers and then
representative
yeah i don't know if this is
the time to do this but i'm going to
bring it up
i'm still concerned that the definitions
of abuse do not include
the
emotional abuse endangerment the false
imprisonment that we talked about the
other day and i didn't know if there was
any um
thought given to including those other
types of abuse that we all agree are
abused but we're not put in here and i
guess that would be to
um
judge lynn and our attorney for mello
so
i'll ask uh attorney general formello to
come up and we should figure this out so
that because
we i i'm viewing the plaintiff and the
attorney general you're sort of a team
you're like two sides of the same coin
so bouncing you back and forth
if we could figure out a way if you're
all comfortable sitting near the same
table that would be great
whatever he feel comfortable with we're
still in a
period of i think a coveted caution
do you remember representative rogers
comment
yes i i believe the question comment was
just whether
consideration had been given to
including things such as
emotional abuse i think the solitary
confinement
and other
categories of conduct such as that
within physical abuse
i guess i would answer that just just to
say that
kind of going to just echo what i've
said before um
we we we have considered that and we
really we really have thought long and
hard about that we've been
thinking about this you know not just
during the discussions on this bill but
we've had a lot of conversations both
internally and with claimants council
before the bill ever
ever got introduced and i
it's really just a matter of where where
you cross that threshold to a point
where it's just very hard to verify
claims and i think that
you know emotional abuse for
for events that took place long ago
you know these are already very it's
already it's difficult enough i think to
go back and kind of suss out um
what happened with regard to sexual
abuse and even harder with physical
abuse i think once you start getting
into things like emotional abuse and
intentional affliction of emotion
emotional distress
that's
those types of claims
arise from actions that
you know it wouldn't just be about
verifying whether whether the stated
actions happen whether statements were
made but it's also in the eye of the
beholder and it depends on depends on
the
the perspective you know the perspective
of a
resident at ydc may be different than a
staff member when it comes to something
that could inflict
say emotional abuse or emotional
distress so
we really have thought long and hard
about that
from my perspective it's it's not a
matter of saying that that isn't
potentially serious conduct or doesn't
potentially have a serious impact on a
resident
it's just so difficult to go back and
and really make a determination as to
what is or is not emotional abuse
that that i think it
those difficulties weren't leaving it
out of the definition for the for the
purpose of a process like this which is
meant to be you know very victim
centered in trauma
trauma informed so not meant to be a
real a really uh
difficult
and uh probing examination of of the
facts when it comes to solitary
confinement we do include that as an
aggregating factor
but again
you know
the fact is is that solitary confinement
was an accepted
uh
accepted way to
an accepted form of punishment if you
will and and i'm not going to make a
comment on whether it was
it was
a good practice whether it ever should
have been the practice but it was a
common accepted practice and
to
i think to have
to have this process include claims
that
don't have physical abuse don't have
sexual abuse only involve solitary
confinement i think i think you're you'd
be opening up the process to a lot of
a lot of former residents
that might have gone through ydc and
there might have been a reason they were
in solitary confinement
it'd be very difficult to to
differentiate the impacts among
residents so i
you know those are just all the things
we've thought about at least from my
perspective as attorney general the
department of justice when we thought
about whether to include those
include those categories of conduct
within
physical abuse for purposes of this
process because this is meant to be
a
a trauma-informed process that will not
involve
very intense probing and examination
so would you remind the committee that
about the
[Music]
the due process that we understand was
involved in making a solitary
confinement decision yes so my
understanding of how the process would
work is that there would be there would
be a committee that would make
a committee
at the facility that would make
determinations on punishment when
when there were acts committed that
might warrant punishment and that
committee would determine whether
someone spent time in solitary
confinement or not
i will say you know i certainly can't
comment on whether there were times when
a when a resident was put in solitary
confinement without going through that
process there i imagine there may have
been times when that happened but that
those would be those would be difficult
to verify and difficult to go back and
reconstruct
thank you representative rogers did you
have a follow-up um
well i i just again to state that i'm
concerned
um that we're leaving some of this out
and especially the solitary confinement
i understand the difficulties but um
we've been pointed out instances that
were people in in solitary confinement
for egregious amounts of time and we've
seen studies that also show the effect
on a child with this so
while i understand that it's difficult i
just think that we're being very
close-minded if you will
by not expanding it some but i'll
leave it at that for now
do you have a
question to
to add to that follow-up or
is that just your ear
you know ask if in fact
it was practiced to leave people in
there for six months which we have
incidences of
i i it's hard for me to hear you i think
if you got the mic closer to your mouth
it would also
and maybe the attorney he said that it
was common practice but is it common
practice to leave someone in there for
six months and i think you know the
acceptance of it was that an accepted
national standard was an accepted local
standard when we say acceptance who was
it accepted
by so so i i think that's a
fair question that would be answered in
a totally different process than what
we're trying to set up here
okay
so
representative leishman i think you were
next
uh thanks mr chairman just like to take
uh representative mooney's
question a little bit further again
going to line 27
is there a need to say single we've
talked about whether it says single or
multiple and just say an incident period
without saying multiple or single
the language i think originated with the
plaintiffs and and so single is in there
out of respect for their input but if if
either of you have a comment on
representative leishman's question
well i think it was previously expressed
that we do want it to be clear that a
single incident is sufficient to bring a
claim to the process we just we want
that clarification
okay
thanks mr chairman i i i would be
happier if it just said an incident and
we made a ann and we struck through
single but
but that's that's just me is i hear
representative weiler just voicing some
support for that
is there is there any i i hate reopening
this up though so
why don't we hang on to that and maybe
we could do it if there's other things
that need to
open up this
with ols
[Music]
did you have a follow-up representative
leashman
okay representative hatch and then
representative walls
uh question answer thank you mr chair
yeah i want to go back and revisit the
whole issue of solitary confinement
particularly in light of what our fine
attorney general has said
and you know i suspect this actually is
one of the areas where there are
probably the clearest records more than
sexual abuse or physical abuse
if you put somebody in solitary campaign
for a number of months that probably is
still in their record from when the time
that they were incarcerated
and
you know i think
the question of what was the standard is
something that can be answered during
the hearings but it can't be answered if
we don't put it in here if we don't make
solitary confinement an issue not an
aggravating factor and given the data
that's out there on the literal
destruction of one's brain by being put
in solitary confinement i think it
should be a stand-alone cause not just a
contributing factor and so i i'm
a little confused by the suggestion that
there isn't information on it because i
suspect there's information on this even
more than the other claims
and i'm very concerned that we're taking
something that could have been so
harmful to these kids and not including
it in this
thank you
so so i'll respond to that and then
representative weiler uh can can speak
next i am
my thought on that is that if there was
an adjudicated decision to incarcer or
to put somebody in solitary confinement
for any period of time
to especially if it was an extended
period of time
um that that there probably is a record
of that but the challenge i'm seeing to
this though
is
that we're opening up claims that go
back as far as possible and
i don't know
i just don't know i honestly don't know
what what is the data retention period
for these files i mean if at some point
some good administrator might have
started throwing out files after they
were 10 15 years old
and
would we create the presumption
of guilt on the part of the state
if we can't produce a record because the
record was destroyed in sort of the
ordinary book bookkeeping of records
so i
i i'm sympathetic to solitary
confinement being severe abuse but i i i
don't know how we can expect this the
state to represent exactly what took
place when we're dealing with things so
long ago that that's just my um
that's just my response to what you're
thinking
[Music]
go ahead
so i i would suggest that issue is going
to occur with all these kinds of abuse
when you go back far enough physical
abuse sexual abuse and solitary
confinement you're going to be on equal
footing for trying to prove or not prove
or find records of or not find records
of i think you're more likely to find
records of solitary confinement than of
anything else but i think if the claim
is old enough they also
could suffer from what you say and that
is a destruction of records and so i'm
not sure why solitary confinement should
be treated differently than any other
older claim
thank you representative wyler
i'm not in favor of
having solitary confinement be something
that should be paid as its damages
if
you've got things to read and you've got
homework to do and all that kind of
thing it's it's almost a welcome
sense of privacy and so on and i don't
know whether that's available or not but
i also look at the secure housing unit
up at the prison where people are in for
years solitary confinement 23 hours a
day all the time i don't want to make a
precedent saying oh that's so damaging
that we're going to pay you big bucks
because they'd be lined up at the door
i'm not going to support solitary
confinement
i i believe we took a straw vote on this
issue uh two days ago and and this is
good discussion but i i think it's
settled at the committee level uh unless
there's anyone who
wants another strava we can certainly do
that i'd like another straw
representative weiler
requests another straw vote um
again this is going to be with division
one and division three members if you're
on division two please withhold your
vote
representative umberger do you have
something to say
uh yes i do
the purpose of this is to
this
process
is to
take care of the sexual and physical
abuse that occurred
at the ydc whatever
cenudo center i don't care where it is
it was not to take care of every ill
that might have been
perpetrated
on a person that is in there
if
this doesn't cover
[Music]
whatever it is
the person has the opportunity to go to
court
just like in this process
if you don't like the decision of the
ag designee
you can back off and go to court
and so if someone
thinks that
solitary confinement is
you know the horrendous problem
and there's nothing else associated with
it then they can go to court
if solitary confinement was part of
sexual abuse or physical abuse
and
they don't like the ag's
designated decision they can still go to
court
we have opened this up significantly
from when we first started
to where you get the first decision
and then you make the decision
whether to go to the administrator
or to go to court
and so
if
i just feel
that
if
if that's what you want to
go after the state for then you do it
through
the court system
and not through this system which is to
help
in some small way
for the state to provide
recompense for
whatever happened
in the past
thank you
uh thank you so uh we're gonna have a
straw vote um there's gonna be two
opportunities to vote the first one will
be you'll raise your hand if you are in
favor of adding solitary confinement to
this bill
um
and the second vote will be
if you are opposed to adding solitary
confinement to the bill i'll i'll i'll
be voting for the second time
so
i'd like to see a show of hands and mr
clerk if you'll help me count
uh raise your hand if you think we
should add solitary confinement as a
reason in and of itself to file a claim
in the statute
in favor is five and then please raise
your hand if you're opposed to adding
solitary confinement
so so we have a
five to eight vote which means that the
straw vote failed and we will not be
adding solitary confinement
okay i i think we'll get through the
other pages a little faster
but that was uh that was page one and i
think the definitional issues are really
key so so i i think that was time well
spent
uh there's nothing on there are no
recommended changes on page two i don't
think oh wait a second mr hoffman i'll
shut up and let you take it
on page two
beginning on line 29
this language was changed and i can read
it or if the committee would prefer not
to hear my voice
we can pause and and and the members can
read it however you wish
i uh i completed reading it and and my
lips were moving while i was doing it so
um
so everyone should have read this by now
uh
mr hoffman do you want to explain to us
what we try to do with this language
well there really uh there are a couple
pieces here there's the
agreement on the administrator the
appointment of the administrator and if
the
attorney general's
designee or the attorney general and the
council don't agree then the supreme
court would
choose an administrator from a
a list of candidates two each provided
and then make it a decision within 30
days
and then starting at the bottom on
line 35 it talks about the compensation
of the administrative
administrator
whether or not they're full-time or
part-time and how they would be paid
so i believe we talked about this quite
a lot on tuesday is there any new
perspectives to be shared
okay so let's let's move on to what
representative von berger i'm i'm sorry
um
it doesn't it doesn't seem to say in
here
when the administrator needs to be
appointed
but later on he has responsibility
to
um
do something starting one november
and so
in other places we have said
the um
you know the ag and we'll get together
and do the guidelines and we'll do this
and do that
but i am concerned that we don't have
a timeline
for
the administrator
that says the administrator will be
appointed by one october or 15 october
or
29 october but it needs to be before
the
claims can be filed which is when
november
otherwise we can't get the data out
unless i'm unless i'm missing something
someplace but
do you think that that needs to be
incorporated into this document or that
the fact that there's a hiring authority
in here that they have the flexibility
to do something rational and hire them
in advance
do you want it in here i have no problem
as long as the ag and the
and the plaintiff's council
recognize that this is something that
will have to be done
as a first step i think
do
do either of you
want to comment on this and by either i
mean the two of you are are one so yeah
i i i think the way i look at it is
given that the
the deadline to kick off the process by
publishing notice is november 1. i think
that kind of provides a deadline to get
the guidelines negotiated and approved
and then the administrator appointed
in time to meet that november one
deadline of publishing notice and
kicking everything off so i think there
is a deadline in here and i think we
would know that we've got a we've gotta
get things done quickly enough so that
we can ultimately meet that november
first deadline
so um from from our standpoint you know
this process once it's once the
guidelines have been established
can't happen fast enough for us so we
have every incentive to
get past the guidelines as well as pick
an administrator in a timely fashion so
i don't see that
a deadline is
necessary all right so i i i'd really
like to not open this document back up
and so i'm not seeing a compelling
reason to do that thank you i don't i'm
not excited about that either okay
i'm
glad we share a common sense of apathy
about that
uh all right so mr hoffman i think we're
on
page three
line
eighteen
oh wait a second representative emerick
i just wanted to comment this says per
diem
the state
per diem is seven and a half hours
is that correct
for the majority of classified employees
it is 37 and a half hours there are
different jobs that are 40 hour
work weeks
okay i i'm
i don't have a
dog in the hunt here i'm just saying is
it is it
which part of the state's per diem
hourly day are we going to use
what line are you on
uh page three line two
one and two
so he's just questioning what the
definition of per diem is in this
context is a 37 and a half hours or i
would have i would have assumed it was
40.
i would assume an eight-hour day but i
just wanted to
throw it out there just just to make
everybody upset
so
you're you're you're taxing my memory on
this a little bit but i think
i think that the way
the judicial branch would conta would
would would consider the per diem rate
for let's say a superior court judge
i think that they would say
you know this in the
these are the work days during the year
and you know so in other words it
wouldn't include it wouldn't include
weekends it wouldn't include holidays
whatever and whatever that you know 365
minus those days are the work days
during the year and then you and then i
believe they divide that by the judge's
yearly salary and say that's the per
diem
rate for a judge for a day and so i
assume
that that's that that's the way
they would they would do it you know
that's the way they would interpret this
to me
okay i is there anyone on the committee
that doesn't want it to be assumed to be
an eight-hour day is what's our intent
here we we want it to be an eight-hour
day right
anyone
yes
so i you know i don't again i don't know
if we need to open up the language to
that
no no
yeah i
i don't think so just because it says it
no more than yeah i don't think
okay so i was talking we decided to do
nothing about that so
uh page 3 line 18 mr hoffman
yes the work group modified this
language to read
the attorney general after making good
faith efforts to reach agreements with
the claimant's counsel
and with input from the attorney
general's victim witness
advocates
shall develop and present
the claims process
so i think the shaded language was
changed from um
from what was in the original bill and
i'm not sure how that ties in with the
uh plaintiff attorney's suggestion so so
the point here was we we just wanted to
make sure there was a line of
accountability and the prior writing was
the joint
responsibility between plaintiffs and
the attorney general so i i think this
language achieves what we said we wanted
to do two days ago
is is there any disagreement on that do
we do we want to open this up for more
discussion or move on
i'm not seeing anyone wanting to talk
further about this so so let's go down
to line whatever that is 20 30.
the bottom of the page is shaded to
indicate that there was a
a suggestion
by a plaintiff's counsel
to have the appointment of a mediator to
resolve disputes and and that language
was not adopted
again i think we talked about this two
days ago and this is consistent with the
straw votes are there any is there any
new information or new perspectives to
share
i'm i'm not seeing any so mr hoffman
would you take us the next item please
next item is on page four starting on
line nine
and it reads
for all claims involving both sexual and
physical physical abuse
or sexual abuse only
no individual no individual claimant
shall be paid more than
one million five hundred thousand
dollars in settlement of all claims in
the ag in the aggregate
for claims involving physical abuse only
no individual claimant shall be paid
more than 150 000
in settlement of all physic
physical abuse claims in the aggregate
so i have a math question to ask the
attorney general if if uh that's
dangerous yeah if um
if somebody came in
and they their
violation was so grievous on the sexual
abuse area and they got the 1.5 million
but then they had a standalone set of
physical abuse only claims
would would
the total amount that they could be
compensated be the 1.5 million or
1.65 million because you would take the
two caps and add them potentially
yeah i think the total would be 1.5
million because the 1.5 million is the
cap for all claims the 150 000 is meant
to just apply to all physical abuse
physical abuse
only claims or all physical abuse claims
so um the 150 000 cap is really just
meant to apply to that claimant who
comes forward with only physical abuse
claims
is there anyone else with the question
on that i
so mister i'm not seeing any mr hoffman
would you go down to line 34.
oh wait oh
i don't do that on on purpose it's just
it's hard to see you back there so uh so
representative rogers please go ahead
yeah the i know we talked about it the
other day and you don't want to reopen
it but
um my concern here is that this is um
is going to be a a
reason for the plaintiffs not to come
forward and go through the settlement
process and instead going to court we do
know that there are
um
there was an average taken but average
doesn't really reflect in a situation
like this
there have been much larger settlements
that have been smaller
around the country for um
similar kind of things and i'm just
asking the attorney general
is there a reason you don't share any
concern that this i know we want to get
as many people to go through this
process as possible
and recently we found
in some of the case the more infamous
cases around the country
of this kind of thing have been much
larger
agreements or settlements and my concern
again is that um
for for trying to do an average because
as i said averages on this you can take
an average but each case is different
each document is different each person
is different so i don't think an average
really reflects so
you don't have any concern that people
are not going to
go forward because of the fact that
we've capped
the award level
yeah thank you representative um
i i think the first point i would i
would say in response is that the
the average that we identified if you'll
recall but i know it was a few meetings
ago was
you know somewhere between 500 and 550
thousand dollars per claimant that that
was the the average we identified when
we looked at
um
past uh verdicts and settlements so
this cap of 1.5 million just to start
it's it's quite a bit higher than even
that national average we identified
i think our goal would be to
you know uh
through the development of the
guidelines design a process where our
average fell
you know roughly around within that
range so not
not too much higher than 500 to 550 000
which what each claimant would end up
getting at the end of the day but
this cap
does provide room for
uh a payment to an individual claimant
of
of significantly over the national
average that we identified at least for
claims that involve sexual and physical
abuse
and as i mentioned i think last time
based on our research you know the the
average for physical abuse claims we
identified was six between 65 and 75 000
per claimant so the 150 000 cap does
allow for going you know significantly
above that and for particular claims
within this process so
so i would just note that as as a first
point in response to your concern
the second point you raise
it's a fair one and it's a good one
and i think yes i have thought about the
fact that
by having a cap of 1.5 million
for all claims 150 000 for physical
abuse claims i think there is a
possibility and it's probably almost a
certainty that there will be some
claimants who
who feel they have a case or who who
have been harmed who have suffered abuse
who might feel that they have a case
that's worth more than these caps and
and they may decide to go to court
i think that that's that's okay i mean i
think our our goal has been to provide
an alternative process that
that offers a quicker and smoother path
to
to resolution the trade-off being in
some cases it may be less money than you
could expect if you go to court
i i would expect that
most will take that option but i've
always had the expectation and i think
we all i don't want to speak for
everyone here but i think we all do i've
always had the expectation that there
may be a small percentage who who would
not elect that option so
it really is a balance between trying to
encourage as many
claimants as possible to come through
the process but
to
keep the numbers at a at a level that's
appropriate for a process that doesn't
involve
the same type of intense
litigation and and verification
investigation that traditional
litigation would if you go through the
traditional litigation process you have
a fully litigated fully discovered case
by the end of it even if the number's
big
you can be more confident i think that
you've really gotten to what i'll just
say you know you've gotten to the truth
the goal of this process is
yes to get to the truth but it's the
primary goal is for to create a smooth
and efficient process that is fair to
claimants and gets them compensation for
for harm so all that said i apologize
for the for the long answer but i just
want to give you a sense again of of my
thinking on this so
um that's those are the factors that
went into it the concern you raise
yes it's on our mind but we've we have
to balance that concern with making sure
these values are appropriate for a
process like this
uh follow-up yeah i have the two i'll
ask them both right now so you can do it
the the two questions i have for you is
what would be the average
is it or to get average but the cost to
your office in litigating a um
a fairly complicated case like one of
these
and secondly do you foresee the
administrator ever saying to someone
that comes forward with a particularly
egregious event um saying you really
should go to court because we're not
going to be able to
obligate you know to
to deal with this this way because of
the cap and so forth if it's something
particularly you know that any of us
would look at and say this this should
get more and i think you're looking at
me like i'm crazy about the time i'm
just curious um
i mean i've administrated administered a
legal office before and i know there's
different ways to break out but i'm just
curious what per case when you prosecute
these cases how many attorneys how long
of their time and and what kind of cost
is there to the office and when they say
cost i don't mean just the the
monetary
yep no and trust me i i'm not looking at
you like you're crazy just kind of
thinking as you talk and so if any
facial expressions are more just trying
to think about the response everybody
thinks i'm crazy
um
so the the first question what's the
average cost
that's difficult to pinpoint
i
you know i
meant it's very rare that even when
these cases do go to court that they end
up going all the way to through trial
and they get to a verdict
but what might happen when you go to
court is that you at least get further
through discovery you get closer to
perhaps uh dispositive motions
and
and you get to a point where you're more
comfortable that each side has the
information they need to have in order
to engage in in settlement discussions
i i think on a case like this we were
just to take one claimant probably
involves a couple of attorneys in our
office
and
i don't have a good sense of how much of
their time
um
it would take it really it's it's a
case-by-case basis it just depends on
how many records are available how
burdensome the discovery is but every
attorney in our litigation unit carries
a very heavy caseload
and even a case like this it's just
and
i don't mean to by saying it's just one
more case i don't mean to discount that
but it it it's another case in their
caseload
so it's very hard to pinpoint what the
costs either are in dollars or or
attorney time for a case because it just
depends but
a case like this
it it's not insignificant i just don't
have an estimate for you
so we've we've had a similar
conversation every hearing and the way i
summarize what i think we're doing here
is the attorney general
and his team has
undergone a data-driven process to get
as much information as they can to
inform them
knowing that this is something that
we've never done before and so
ultimately this is
i think is going to rely on on just best
judgment and the humility that we might
be wrong but we're trying to get it as
right as we can that that
that's my take
and
i see you shaking your head yeah so i i
won't go to you but representative
umberger
yes this is uh this is to answer
part of one of
representative rogers questions she said
would the administrator ever tell a
person to go to court well the bottom
line is that it would never get to the
administrator for that decision
because the decision needs to be made
at the ag designee
level and so
if the if they decide not to go to go to
court then the administrator is really
not involved
so thank you
representative wyler
let's not lose
sight of the fact it's an experimental
process which never been done before
we're trying to deal with hundreds of
cases
trying to minimize the amount of time it
would take
to settle them
and some of these people are willing to
to settle for a lot less than we think
and
the idea is to find those and get those
cases out of the way obviously we know
from the beginning that many will want
to go to court the first few it may take
three or four years before they get
there and then they might have a jury
that decides you're getting zero
there's always that chance
so
at least by going through this process
it's likely you'll get some money
so i think a lot of people will look at
the odds and say well i want money now
and they're just gonna go ahead with
this process as proposed and not
dream of getting becoming an instant
millionaire because they're going to
court i don't think that will happen i
think the first one or two that go all
the way to court are going to be sadly
disappointed thank you
all right
i didn't hear a question in there so um
i think we're getting ready to move on
uh just for situational awareness
the house republicans started their
decorum meeting at 3 p.m and so for
those of you that are missing it i will
give you constructive credit for that as
long as you behave so
so mr hoffman would you take us to line
yes line 13 you'll see the shaded
november 1st 2022 that used to read
december 1st 2022 provides one extra
month
an earlier publication of notice so
there's happens a little sooner
all right i'm not
seeing any conversation there do you
want to go to 34 line 34
line 34
was added to to read once a claim has
been properly filed by a living former
ydc resident
the subsequent death of that claimant
shall not extinguish the claim
i i think we had a good conversation two
days ago on that and that seems to hit
what we said is there any
discussion on that
i'm not seeing any so
if you would take us to page five
line
eight
the language here was revised to read by
filing a claim the claimant agrees that
he or she will participate in the claims
process and if the claimant requests
that the administrator decide the claim
agrees to accept the determination of
the administrator as final and binding
even if the claimant does not receive
any payment from the fund
okay so in the past when we've discussed
this section um
i i i wanted to be sensitive to whether
or not the plaintiffs
read this language and can accept this
this is
is this acceptable to you the way this
is framed
so um
we believe this is stated properly and
consistent with what
you know the way this bill is
constructed so yes we're fine with it
all right thank you um if there's no
further
discussion or questions uh let's go down
to line 33 mr hoffman
line 33 is
added reference to the right to know
statute 91a
and that ties in with the
discussion later on toward the end of
the amendment uh regarding the right to
know information
all right so let's uh let's defer if
there are any questions on that to the
other bigger discussion so i think we're
on
line
six
or excuse me page six line seventeen
this language was added starting on 17.
um
would you like me to read it or give
everyone a chance to read it uh b let's
go ahead and read it individually
i still see people reading so
can you add some context of what the
work group attempted to do with this
section
i would defer to the um
main participants of the work group
mr attorney general
yeah this
this language was added it actually
mirrors language that appears later in
the bill but as we were going through
the bill yesterday i realized that
while later in the bill there's language
regarding
um advising the
the claimant of their of their options
and then
giving the
giving the claim in a certain amount of
time to indicate their response to the
a.g designee's position
that language came
after a claim was referred to an
investigator we didn't have language to
address what happens for claims that
aren't referred to an investigator so
we i just thought we should add the same
language to to apply so it applies to
claims that aren't that are never
referred to an investigator in the first
place
just so mr hayden or dean do you do you
have any comment on this
i'm gonna take credit for raising this
issue last tuesday and i'm gonna give
the attorney general credit for properly
wording it in this amendment
all right success
very nice so let's go
to
page 7
line 8 mr hoffman
line 8
clarifies that the
claimant will be advised in writing
and then
at the end
instead of withdrawing his or her claim
it adds from further processing
any comment and question on that
i'm not seeing any uh do you want to go
to
line 13 please
um there is one more note on that that
last one that i missed the work group
removed a sentence stating that an
explanation
shall be provided of how the attorney's
fees are impacted by resolution process
and that was
determined to be unnecessary
because of the change to the cap on
legal fees
just um
would you would you stick my nose into
where um the
uh 33 and a third percent what's what
part of the
bill is that on
are we going to be reading that later on
so so i'll i'll ask that question later
yes it is on page nine all right um
okay
so we we
opened up
uh line eight and ten i don't think we
have any comments on those uh
do we wanna go are you ready for line
thirteen yes
that should probably be
all of uh subsection 8 should probably
be read together with the changes
within 30 days of receiving
the updated position of the aeg designee
the claimant shall indicate to the
administrator and the ag designee
whether he or she agrees with the ag
designee's position
whether he or she wishes for the
administrator to decide the claim
or whether he or she wishes to withdraw
the claim from further processing
in the absence of an indication from the
claimant the administrator may assume
that the claimant is in agreement with
the position of the ag designee
if the claimant and the ag designee are
in agreement regarding the disposition
of the claim
the administrator shall make an award
consistent with the party's agreement
does anyone
have a question or comment on that
section
section h
are is everyone getting enough time to
actually have an opportunity to speak up
if they see something
because we i am trying to move through
this
but i don't want to override anyone's
speaking
i think we're on page eight
and we're down to line 17.
there was another
recommendation in the margin
next to line 18 on page seven
that the work group opted not to include
language making the claim and aware in
writing of his or her options and the
reason for that is the issue was
addressed elsewhere
in the bill
when you say elsewhere is it
to come still or did we cover that part
of the bill
uh
it was addressed on page seven line
eight
and
okay
thank you
so
i believe we're on page nine line nine
i think we have some a change on page
eight
at um
line 17
i thought we just did that good go ahead
thanks for the catch this has to do with
the
situation where there may have been a
mathematical error miscalculation
it provides that the claimant or the aeg
designee may request the administrator
to reconsider decision
uh based on mathematical mistakes or
miscalculations
okay okay
um
plaintiffs do you have a comment or
concern or anything you want to talk
about here that change is fine
thank you
any other comments questions
so so now we're at nine nine i sound
like a german
nine-nine that's the uh
that's the language that deals with the
uh attorney's fees and it reads the
administrator shall not approve any
request
of an attorney fee or costs which are
not reasonable
the attorney uh the administrator shall
not approve
an attorney's
fee in excess of 33 and a third percent
of the amount of the award
all costs and attorney fees paid to
claim it this attorney shall be paid
from the amount awarded to the claimant
all right i think we talked about that a
good deal tuesday and this is consistent
with what we agreed on then so art but
does anyone have any new comment or
consideration to throw in here
representative weiler did you have
something you wanted to say sir
i just said we agreed to eliminate 25
percent and
judge lynn's recommendation make it all
33 and a third so there was no incentive
to go beyond the first step thank you
it is as i understand it it's a little
more nuanced than that the 33 and a
third percent gets to be the ceiling and
the administrator could choose a lower
contingency fee depending on what's
reasonable
exactly exactly right yes the 33 and a
third is the cat is the maximum
thank you um
okay so let's uh
drop down
to line 25 i think it's 20.
and this is the the language that
concerned with the right to know
information
the shaded language was agreed to by the
committee on tuesday
and the new language reads
records of the youth development center
claims administration in the ydc
settlement fund pursuant to rsa 21m
going 11-a with the exception of
settlement agreements which shall remain
subject to
right to know
and after a claim has been finally
resolved
such other records the release of which
would not constitute a violation of the
provisions of law or an unwanted
invasion
of a claimant's
privacy and the section being amended
there are the exemptions to the right to
know law
so i think this is consistent with what
we talked about on tuesday and i i'm
just curious this is more trivia than
essential but
has has since we've drafted this
particular version has anyone heard from
the union leader or ms timmins who spoke
on this
okay i i
we haven't gotten feedback i
i this this is this represents to me a
good faith effort to address
the concerns of the media
uh i may be wrong i'm not a lawyer uh so
let's go to line 35.
um well i'm sorry representative walner
i didn't see you go ahead even though uh
i know that there's going to be no
change here i
we now hit the appropriations line and i
know that's not read it's not going to
be changed
we agreed upon it that last time you
brought in the amendment you brought in
to take it from the rainy day fund and i
just want to remind everybody that there
is a very specific way
that you go into the rainy day fund and
i think it's really respond
irresponsible of us
as the finance committee
to have a to have a bill we're
presenting to the legislature
that spends hundred million dollars
without people understanding that we're
bypassing
the law that um
governs the rainy day fund
and so i have a copy of the rainy day
fund law for everyone
so that they can review it and we can be
certain we understand clearly what we're
doing
it's really a serious situation because
taking money from the rainy day fund
will affect our bond rating or may
affect our bond rating which is going to
be a problem in the future
so i think i have a copy for everyone
and i think i think it's just something
that we should be sure that people
understand what they're doing
when uh we're on the floor with this
bill
i i appreciate what you're saying and as
a relatively junior member of this
committee i i want to hear from people
with uh more
seniority than i have so
representative leishman is your hand up
is it or are you just no not yet
representative emmerich representative
weiler representative humberger do you
do you have anything to say here
i would i would just say that
before
um i made the decision to take it from
the rainy day fund i did look at the
at the requirements
i'm well aware of them
and i
won't argue with you
that um
it's difficult
and i also know that
neil kirk is probably standing right
behind me with a big fat bat
and no kidding this is where i learned
this and uh you know and i i won't deny
that
but i also know that um
our rainy day fund is uh
higher than it's ever been
by about 100 million dollars and so um
that that's where you know all that
stuff together
pointed here
now we can we can also um
you know make the assumption
that our revenues
from 23 and the lapses that occur
will be more than
million dollars um
and so
you know
i guess it's a flip of a coin
as to
as to what we do
i don't think any of us
no matter how long you've been in the
legislature
have ever been in a position
where
there is this much money out there and
that's not including
all the arpa and the cares and all that
other stuff that we have been
we've been dealing with this is just you
know state revenue
that i don't we've never
i haven't been here forever but i know
some of you have
and
i don't mean i don't that's probably the
wrong thing to say have been here a lot
longer than i have
and
it's just
absolutely unprecedented so
that's
and i i would agree
may i speak go ahead
i would
sorry about that i would agree that it
is the most money probably i've ever
seen flowing into the state
but
the time will come when all this arpa
money
cares money all that will dry up and we
will be back again to being dependent
on our own resources
and if the time comes
when new hampshire has a financial
problem
and we have drained the rainy day fund
or we have taken a significant amount
out
then we will
have
we will be facing a financial problem
and i just think it's something to take
very seriously
by the members of the finance committee
and i
will tell you i learned this from a
member of your party
who um
really understood this very well and
taught me many times about the
importance of the rainy day fund
so just i i do want to pass the
i want to pass the law out and you've
probably all seen it and looked at it
but you'll have your own personal copy
and you can just bring it out and take a
look at it before you go to bed at night
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman i've
sat in this committee for more than a
dozen budgets i've seen the rainy day
fund go up and down and i've seen many
uh administrations that as soon as they
started the budget process they took
almost everything out of the rainy day
fund that's not uncommon um
i think this is a good idea because of
what we heard in discussions from ways
and means telling us this 200 million
dollars
that we're counting as revenue
that is as a result of um
you know payroll protection plan that
we're forgiving their taxes on as well
as credit carry forward
that's getting up over about 100 million
so there's what we think of 200 million
that we have in revenue
is somebody else's money that we're
going to likely have to pay back we
don't know when or over what period of
time but
when they brought that out to my
attention i thought whoa we're not
nearly as far ahead of this revenue as
we thought we were so
um it's not unusual for us to use rainy
day fund usually it doesn't go into the
middle of the budget but
too often it started the budget by
grabbing that money right away so
it's not unusual for money to go in and
out of them the
rainy day fund
and it's unusual for it to come out in
the middle but i think it's happened
before when we had a mistake on the
revenue thank you
so
so i have a question and maybe this is
for you representative umberger um
as i understand the core of your
position it's it's like the rainy day
fund is an empty coffee can
and we're going to open the bottom of it
to pull the 100 million out of this
but at the same time we've got
a spigot
putting 100 million into the top of the
can so so net net
it's it's no effect on the rainy day
fund is is that is that a fair
interpretation
uh
the the spigot doesn't open until june
of 23
at the end of the biennium
so
between
whenever this passes and the money comes
out
the
rainy day fund would be short 100
million but not short would be a hundred
million dollars less
okay
it would be 100 million less but then
we're anticipating 100 million more
flowing to the rainy day fund
i'm just trying to understand what
you've said yeah a lot you know all i
can say is a lot depends
on
how much of the
200 and
i can't remember the number 200 plus
million
that is currently in
bills that are sitting here in finance
how much of that goes
so
as to how much is actually in the um
i'll call i don't i'll call it revenue
above projections
so but yes uh and of course what's not
included in that are the lapses
and i think all of us know
at least
on the fiscal committee
we got a list of all the vacancies that
are out there
and i mean there are hundreds of them
and that's all going to lapse
and you know at the end of at the end of
this year
so i mean it's you know
it's a it's a crapshoot you know and uh
i'm not very good at craps
i i wouldn't want to interpret this is
as is a gamble i would say that this is
you're you're you're considering the
risks there is some risk to lower
revenues than what we're seeing now over
the final 16 months of the fiscal year
but that based on lapses and and
your judgment and experience
we're going to be ending up putting 100
million back in that we're pulling out
here right is that
again i'm not trying to put words in
your mouth i'm just trying to protect
you from the media
[Laughter]
i think that's a that's a fair statement
okay so representative
i didn't mean to cut you off
representative walls and then we'll go
to was that you represent griffin yeah
and then representative hatch go ahead
representative walls i just have a
question for our esteemed chairman here
and that is have you talked to the
treasurer
about what it's going to mean on the
bonds or anything else the state is
doing to drop this by 100 and then
anticipate putting the other 100 in but
how the market's going to
look at it and
what how are they going to react what's
that going to do to the state
um nothing
we did
i don't remember when it was ken that we
had the conversation with the treasurer
not about this particular
dollar figure but about
whether or not
the um
amount of money in the rainy day fund uh
made a difference in our
bond breeding and so on and
i think she said it was kind of a wash
that that's consistent with the
conversations i've had with the treasure
one on
on ways and means the the
the rainy day fund is a factor that the
bond
experts look at but they're looking more
at the aggregate on the overall
management and position of the state and
so although the rainy day fund is a
factor it's not a particularly
significant one and so when we raised
the amount that we were going to put in
i was told that it probably would not
have a positive effect on our bond
rating that
so
represent griffin on the same subject
i'd like to point out that when they do
the bond rating they consider all the
liabilities the state may have not just
the balance sheet liabilities they look
at the footnotes
and they look at the potential suits
against the state
and this takes one of those potential
suits
and lowers the impact of it
uh thank you for that was that you
representative hatcher that had your
hand i just
i hesitate to mention this but i i'm
having a little flashback
and i'm thinking about 2008 the last
time we had to use the rainy day fund
um
we were in a very similar circumstance
talking about our finances a year prior
to that a year and a half prior to that
and then when
everything fell out of the bottom
the rainy
day fund was woefully short
of what we needed to operate this state
as it was being operated we had to make
draconian cuts
and
our salvation then though was in part
the tremendous amount of aid we got from
the federal government
the next biennium
and i'm just concerned and maybe we
ought to consider the fact that i'm not
sure that same level of aid
and rescue
will be there for us when the
stuff hits the fan this time and and i'm
just concerned that it may be sooner
than later that's um
and i'm not a defender of the rainy day
fund by most means but i am now
concerned and i don't think we're in
quite a rosy state as we
think we may be just based on what has
happened previously that's all thank you
mr
i'd like to ask you a question and then
we'll go to represent weiler and um
is it your would it be your position
that
we should
defer funding this until the next fiscal
year and we just put it straight out
into the budget now i'll ask the same
question of representative walner uh not
not the least i think
based on the revenues that coming that
are coming in
and what we have now we may very well be
able to fund this
um without a heavy reliance upon the
ready to refund that's that's the only
thing and and i just learned from neil
kirk us
also and that's the last gap effort the
rainy day fund i mean he is standing
with that baseball bat i can see his
shadow right now but it's just
it concerns me that that's all not a
criticism or anything else i'm just
thinking back to what occurred not too
many years ago thank you
thank you representative waller do you
want to respond to my question
i think the way the bill was drafted in
this section from at the beginning was
the correct way to do it take it from
the general fund
we know now that right now that our
revenues are coming in stronger i heard
the reason
that we want to take it from the rainy
day fund
is because
let's see if i can come up with how to
describe this
the reason we want to take it from rainy
day fund is that it's like
it's like if i got a raise at work
and i decided i'm going to spend all
that oh boy i'm going to spend all that
and i'm still going to go over here in
my savings account and i'm going to take
out
enough money to buy myself a new car
that's what we're doing so we want to
spend all the revenue that's coming in
that was the answer i had the first time
i asked the question we want to we
anticipate all the bills that are coming
and we want to spend
all of those
and we want to spend from our savings
account
i think it's just
to think about
and
we are the finance committee
and we should
um
think about this and
make sure we are
clear with what we're doing
and i'm most concerned that we be clear
with the full house
when we're on the floor that they
understand
that what they're what they're doing
i agree with the transparency i i
last or two days ago or maybe it was a
previous one
i
i i rationalized this without being an
expert in the rainy day fund law
that
going back to 1990 and even earlier
we were accruing
unseen liabilities
over all of that course of time so we we
we are now recognizing that we've
accrued
decades of liability
the money that's in the rainy day fund
has also accumulated over some number of
years
and i see some logic on looking at this
kind of from an accrual perspective is
that we should try to match the accrued
revenues with the accrued liabilities
does is that argument uh persuasive in
the least with
you i don't think you have to persuade
me you have to persuade the other 400
people on the floor
on the floor but but your opinion
matters more to me than there so i'm i
am asking is that at all a persuasive
argument for you
um no not really
all right thank you representative
big picture numbers
biennium budget 13 billion dollars
one third of that roughly is going to
employee wages and benefits
that's about four billion dollars
when we looked in division three
at the hhs and we found
they were short a thousand employees
that allowed us to take 70 million
virtually out of that hhs budget
which
balanced the budget we were 70 million
short of what hhs told us
if we have
3 000
vacancies which is likely what we're
hearing
that's going to be three times that so
if if we were able to get
um
that much money from vacancies 70
million and so it's say it's three times
that that's almost two billion
so
uh you know i'm not worried about
as as uh the chairman pointed out when
we look at all the lapses
it's to be big money
and
you know that's that's money that's
we put in a budget that will not be
spent
so it's going to lapse there's no other
place for it to go
and we're still functioning even short
of people as we are thank you
representation
uh thank you mr chairman so
i sat next to neil kirk in division one
i sat next to neil in the full committee
we used to call him mr neil but
i look at this situation first of all
i'm disgusted with what happened whether
it be at the sununu center or elsewhere
it
and i share the same concerns as my
colleagues behind me and in front of me
and to the side as far as
where the money is coming from
but i think if it comes from the rainy
day fund in my particular
viewpoint that sends a good message
because we know the money is there
um
and
we're you know as representative
wireless that we heard a week or so ago
in fiscal we have perhaps as many as 3
000 vacancies in state government but
we don't know what can happen in the
next 15 or 16 months
but at least with the rainy day fund
right now it stands at about 256 million
dollars
and to me knowing that that money is
there and would be guaranteed to
whatever settlements that may be
forthcoming
um those individuals out there know the
state's word is there because the money
is there
so i'll support it coming out of the
rainy day fund
so i don't i don't see a need for a
straw vote on this because we we'd
already had accepted it but i'll
entertain if somebody wants to have a
straw vote on this
all right all right i
i think it was a good conversation i i i
learned something i i learned i need to
do better to persuade you in the future
so that's good so
uh uh oh yeah representative walsh
please
thank you i just have a comment that i
find it ironic that the so-called tax
and spend democrats are the ones that
don't want to spend the extra 100
million dollars and the other side of
the aisle is when advocating spending
100 million dollars it's an unusual role
reversal that i just want to bring to
people's attention that
we seem to be the frugal ones this time
i as i understand representative
weiler's comments in the past the in and
the yang have been backwards and the
blue party
took from the rainy day fund to fund
their budget plans at the outset so it
isn't that we're so different it's just
our timing is different but
uh representative umber yeah
i hope that from that comment uh
representative walls that you don't mean
that we shouldn't
pass this bill
okay okay
all right thank you because
my only reference is whether we raid the
rainy day fund
so that we can spend the full 250
million in surplus or we pull the rate
this out of the surplus so we spend less
of the surplus and maintain the rainy
day fund absolutely we should fund this
the question only is
where do we take it from i got it okay
but that that was not how it sounded
so
thank you
oh all right i think we're ready to move
on do you remember where we are uh we we
took us a side track but uh it was a
good one
are we on line 25 or lower
35 we're on the last change
and this is the sunset language
we uh we asked ols to provide language
to repeal the law either on termination
of the fund on june 30th
or
when it's determined that
the fund is
no longer
needed as stated on page two
so this repeal language would repeal
all of this new
statute and the change to the right to
know law
okay so so much of this is the first
time we're reading the repeal language
so let's take a moment to make sure
everyone's had a chance to read it
representative lynn do you have a
comment you know i really just have a
question and i'm i'm frankly not sure of
the answer but i i raised the question i
have no problem
with the with the sunset provision with
regard to section two
i just have a question about
is there
is there really a reason to repeal
section three i i mean i understand that
once this
once the uh
uh
this whole claims process is done
the
it would be it will be unlikely that the
that the uh
somebody would make a request to get
access to records
you know after that time as opposed to
earlier but maybe
you know i mean what it what if what if
in 2035
after this is all resolved somebody
wants to get access to some
records of a settlement
or something about a settlement that
happened in 2025
would
wouldn't wouldn't you want the same
law
as to as to
right to know access
to be in existence and so i that that's
my only question
uh personally i i agree with that
concern completely i
just reading it i can't tell
if
if that portion the right to no portion
is
repealed at the same time is it
um
i think it
i think it is if i read the language
correctly i think it is it says that
section two which is the basically the
bulk of the bill
um
and
the rsa 91 a5 13 which is what we've
added in section three
um
are
shall be repealed so i think it does
apply to both
a
comment
yes
this is an experimental program looking
at it that way did it
work some years later we'll decide did
it work was it good thing we did
if it did then we may want to revitalize
what we did before and it will still be
available but
i don't know if we want to
take a different approach because there
are things in here that are unique and i
thought i considered this one of them
so
you know
after we after we can evaluate when this
is all said and done if something comes
up again would we revisit this process
and it would always be available to put
the same language back in another bill
because it would be whole
i'm sure that once we do another process
we'll say we should change this we
should have changed that going back over
it there will be changes so
looking at this is an experimental
process i'm sure that i can
figure out whether we did the right
thing or not by repealing that which we
created thank you
so so representative glenn i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna go with your instinct on this
and think that maybe
the repeal needs to be tweaked so that
the right to know
language
lives beyond for these records uh do you
think what's what what's your
legislative opinion should we reopen
this with ols to tweak the language
or should we go ahead and take a vote on
this total bill and pass it to full
finance
uh and while you think of that answer
i'll i'll go to
mr hayden i think there's a other
dimension to this question that really
should be considered
and you know i i generally agree with
the statement that you know this fund in
this process was expected to be around
until it was no longer needed
the issue is that those words don't
actually exist in this bill
and
you know in going back to page three
it just says unless early discontinued
by the attorney general in consultation
with the administrator
so when you tie that to the repeal of
the process
it sort of
seems like there's no restrictions on
the attorney general's right
authority to effectively ask for you
know the termination of the fund
uh and the repeal of the law
so
you know i don't think that's what
anyone intends but i think that's the
way the words could be read
so i i think i've been maybe the loudest
advocate for a sunset provision on this
and maybe i'm wrong it would would it
just be better to strike all of the
repeal language knowing we got 10 years
to get it right
go ahead
turn mr attorney general yeah i mean the
more i've thought about this the more i
think it's probably better to let the
legislature just repeal this ten years
from now or whatever we
i mean the legislature's done that
before where it will just repeal
something once the time comes to repeal
it i think that that's another way to to
handle this and i
i've wrestled with whether there are
other provisions of the bill that really
need to stay in place i think
they probably don't but
the safer course of action
given the concern raised with the 91a
provision may just be to
to take this section out and rely on
whoever's in the legislature 10 years
from now to repeal it
when when the time comes
so representative berger are you going
to remember to repeal this in 10 years
absolutely
i'll put it on my calendar okay okay
okay so
representative lynn i did say i'd come
back to you for your thoughts on this
what do you think
you know i i i
think i i agree with representative
umberger and the attorney general that
it that seems like a better
you know maybe we could
the the attorney general is gonna is
required to give reports periodically
you know maybe at the
when the
you know on the last report so to speak
he might say and by the way
you
you folks in the legislature may want to
consider repealing this now that it's
all over and then and by that point
we'll have had
all the experience with with the
operation of it so that if there are
other provisions besides the right to
know law that should be kept in effect
or something
uh he can make that recommendation to us
all right
i don't want to fall on that sword i i
just like the idea the concept of
cleaning up after ourselves if we know
this is a temporary project that's going
to end i just like
having it
so you know have the garbage take itself
out you know but
but it seems like the cleanest thing to
do at this point would be to repeal it
if we're going to open this back up to
ols
i would like to go back to page one and
strike the word single that's used on
line
27 and line 30 and who said that i did
uh uh representative
so before we leave that just so i
understand
back on page 2 line 18 if i read that
correctly the fund ends on june 30th
2032 is that not correct
so why wouldn't we just repeal it on
june 30th 2032.
i i i think what we're noticing is that
there may still be
public interest in the records and the
right to know provisions ought to
survive because in particular
we are
tweaking 91a a little bit in this bill
okay fair enough so leave that if that's
important but why not get rid of the the
other parts and let the money go back to
the stabilization fund
not if it's not terminated
representative
this is um not
uh
has no
has no effect on our previous statement
that it's going to
lapse to the
rainy day fund in 20
or
yeah 2032.
yeah i understand that's what i'm
reading so we still need section two of
the bill after that point
which is basically the majority of the
except for the rsa the uh the uh so just
i'm a little confused so you on please
help me page nine
line 35 where we start the repeal
section the sunset provision
are you are you are are you taking issue
on whether or not we should delete
that um
that that paragraph five on repeal the
whole paragraph
i'm asking about sort of the other half
of what you were worried about you you
want the rsa 91 a step back and left in
there as i understand it and i'm not
quibbling that i'm just still wondering
why the other part
needs to remain
section two it does it doesn't
we're we're not touching section two
no no if i'm not mistaken the repeal
repeals sections two and section three
am i not reading that correctly that's
correct
we're saying we would repeal those as
you want section three i get it
but do you want section two
why is that not being why would we not
repeal that is my question to the ag i
guess
there
there are a number of provisions
in
i think in all of section two that that
one might argue should stay in place
there's a provision in there that talks
about the fact that the publication of
notice
you know is
also constitutes um
notice for purposes of sort of uh
beginning
or cutting off any tolling of the
statute of limitations so once that
notice is published
there's no doubt that the three-year
statute of notation starts to run for
any claims
there's just some other provisions in
there i think that that
that
some may feel like should stay around so
people can can look back and see in the
rsas that this happen that said i also
don't
i don't have a huge concern with the
bill
with the sunset provision i think my my
thought was just
it's probably safe or not to sunset it
with that i do apologize mr chair i need
to leave i have to go back to the office
for something
um so
i i think we're really close okay so i
appreciate everything you've done on
this
so thanks yup thank you thank you all
thank you john sir
okay so
representative er i i i just i just hate
the idea
i'm sorry if he's leaving i'll drop it
like my last question would have been
for him so
i know
okay i i i just want to explain myself
and and why i think just deleting
paragraph five starting on line 35 and
running to the next page 10 going
through line four just removing that
is is just the cleanest way to
make sure that
we don't accidentally break something
here i i hate doing legislation on the
fly in a
committee like this so i i am trying to
move us towards a vote so we can get
this to the finance committee so it's i
think we need to have a clean
um motion
all right
um so so we'll do a straw vote on this
um
i i
i i like this amendment a lot and and
but i think we've had a conversation
about
uh
starting at page nine line 35 where
section five on repeal begins
and then ends
on page 10 line four
i'd like to take a straw poll to see
who would be in favor of
removing that section
and then the other vote would be who is
in favor of keeping it so
uh does everyone understand what what
the straw vote is going to be
uh raise your hand if you think we
should delete
section 5 or paragraph 5 on repeal
one two three four
five
six seven
uh those in favor of retaining the
repeal paragraph
so so that was seven four yes okay um
did we lose two people or is my mouth
that bad
because the other we had an eight five
at one point
um
okay leaving it is a
not four it'd be five
okay
uh all right uh and then uh since that
would cause us to open this up with ols
uh i would propose that on line 27 of
page one
that we change
a single
to
ann
so that it reads means and incident
and similarly on line 30
change the a single to
and
so this this is basically just saying an
incident
[Music]
mr chairman
could you ask um
the uh
folks sitting at the table what their
take is on changing those words
taking out single
yes ma'am i i think we got their input
earlier but
it's been a long time so
do you have an opinion
so
you know the
determining what's an incident is is a
big part of the discussion in the
resolution of a claim
and you know this bill is not going to
define
you know that incident it's going to be
defined determined in the guidelines um
you know the use of the word incident
here
is extended to tie to c which is one of
more incidents right so it it's i think
it's clear the bill does capture both
incidents you know
and allowed to be discussed both
individually and collectively and that's
a long way of saying this change would
be okay
thank you
okay so if you raise your hand on the
straw vote you're voting in favor of
striking a single and just replacing it
with the word an a-n
so all those in favor of that change
please raise your hand
anyone opposed
i'm not seeing any opposed um so
um
mr hoffman and mr ripple
what i think i want to do is i want to
take a
a committee vote division one division
three that are here
on
um the umberger amendment
with
all of the changes that we've gone
through and have accepted
uh in in in into the next well i guess
they're already in here right
okay so we have to do one more amendment
though to strike repeal and strike the
word single
uh i'd like to have a vote
on
accepting that you guys are going to do
it right so that we can get out of your
way and you can get this ready for the
finance committee
is that is that within protocol
okay
mr chairman i'd make that motion
all right
uh we're going to take a roll call on
this right
okay so this is uh
i i think this is an otpa
vote um with the umberger amendment uh
with the
chain the the two changes that we
specified
let's start with uh representative
berger she has a question
no i don't have a question we had three
changes
we had strike
paragraph five
change
line
and to strike single right and on line
30. yeah you're being precise i was
considering no no you're absolutely
right
i i was i was lumping those since
they're so similar into one but
you are precise
so um
do we need to change the motion
nope all right so let's go ahead with
the
roll call
yes
representative
yes representative
yes
representative walnut yes
representative
yes
chairman edwards yes
all right
the committee the joint committee has
approved um the otpa on a 13-1 vote
12-1 okay
that makes sense all right uh
so with that i i think we've completed
our work here we'll no we haven't what's
what's our more work we have to
come up with who's going to do the
blurbs or what thank you i will do
the
blurb for the positive side and i just
wondered if there is
going to be a uh
a
a minority um i
could possibly vote yes in full
committee
i've got some things i need to think
about that i'm concerned with this but
if they're if i do vote no i will write
a report for it i'm not
opposed to the bill at large they're
just a few sections that i'm concerned
with so um
it'll be kind of a positive negative
verb
okay
so representative rogers
trying to be precise i i think your vote
is recorded as an as a no and then you
can't change that unless we reopen the
vote no i'm not going to change it here
i said in full committee oh in full
committee okay all right very good and
then you'll write the blurb if you
keep your position i got it thank you
okay now i think we're done
we're going to refer this to the full
finance committee on tuesday okay
so with that uh thank you uh i
it feels like a pretty good bill to me
uh but we don't know until we've done it
for a couple years so um so thank you
very much that will adjourn hb 1677.
hmm
you